well you know him you love him he's the
host of fox across america welcome jimmy
[Applause]
yo nashville
hey girl
i gotta tell you i love this crowd
because you are living in a free country
and that is amazing
yo where i'm from in new york
everybody's got three masks they're
scared to leave the house the only thing
people are scared of in nashville is
running out of beer let's be honest
it's so true
you know for those of you watching on tv
at home who don't speak nashville woo is
a word that means anything you want
after six beers am i right
right
you want another beer woo but i'm just
telling you
i love it because this town does not
give an f you know what i'm saying
listen
i was getting i got picked up at the
airport guy driving a cab i was like hey
man do i need to wear a mask downtown
and he goes only if you plan on robbing
a bank
and then he made a right turn and he was
like whoo and i was like damn
i had a great christmas but i got to
tell you man
this supply chain is a mess okay my wife
jenny fella she wanted one of those
amazon alexas for christmas you know the
personal assistant and answers questions
so i go out i spend all this money on an
alexa but the supply chain gets screwed
up they send me this cheap knock off
that doesn't take questions called a
kamala
and uh
but yo
it's bad every time you ask it a
question its assistant cuts it off and
the driving directions are useless it
doesn't know how to get to the southern
border it's really bad
but seriously 2021 will forever be
remembered as the year that we freed
britney and put our president into a
conservatorship think about that
yo for real though like i don't care how
you vote one way or the other like you
have to admit joe biden is the only
human being you know who quits talking
in the middle of a sentence because he's
done you know what i'm saying
he like
you know
the rapidly rising i don't know yo this
dude is sending in the punt team on
second down it's not good
and i care man i'm raising a kid in this
country 13 year old lincoln fella my son
lincoln great kid but that name became
controversial with the woke crowd this
year so now he's going by his middle
name oj
and um
but i really do like i pay attention to
the country and i think if you really
wanted to help in 2022
everybody needs to calm down seriously
calm down for real folks here's the
thing really quick just hear me out
everybody we live in the greatest
country the world has ever known it's a
statement of fact there's never been a
more tolerant time in our society than
right now there's never been a more
inclusive time in our workforce than
right now but everybody's so busy
fighting on social media like we're
missing a great party i'll give you a
good example man like the navy admitted
this year that aliens came to america
and no one even noticed the news story
think about that e.t didn't phone home
he took an uber and no one cared because
we were fighting on twitter
i it should have been a big story if for
no other reason than because it was the
only alien that got sent back under
biden and here we are
you guys
but i'm just saying like if you want to
help the situation just calm down a
little bit you know because people don't
realize how out of their minds they are
like on facebook everybody has a
facebook friend who's become like a
constitutional lawyer that's writing
like 9 000 word essays if anybody cares
facebook needs a button called who asks
you you know what i'm saying
my buddy paints houses he wrote a 9 000
word essay about the debt ceiling i'm
like yo benjamin moore how about you
stick to the living room ceiling and we
all get on with our lives
the other thing oh hey my man wow
there's like a little kid right here in
nashville get him a beer come on
you call this a town
[Applause]
oh little what great parenting right
there
i love it
and i and i love your mom because every
time you laugh you show a little more
cleavage in that dress so thank you
very nice
this is amazing
but seriously two things you gotta do
okay you gotta calm down you got to
support the cops we have to support the
cops
if you are a man or a woman who puts on
the uniform thank you we love you you're
important to us
and everybody needs to know that like i
know that because everyone in my family
is a cop like i would have been a cop if
it weren't for this thing called a
background check but if it wasn't for
that you never know but it's amazing
because my brother just became a cop in
new york city and i called him up the
first day to wish him good luck and our
days were like identical it was insane i
was like hey man how you making out so
far he was like good i just spent the
last three hours trying to see if this
guy had wheat on him then i was
following a hooker for two blocks i was
like holy crap me too
he's like as a matter of fact we're
about to bust the massage baller on 49th
street i was like listen i gotta go take
care
best advice i can give you man i say
this every day on fox across america and
that's why at my host box across america
which i just want to clear up the
confusion because i know we have a lot
of music acts here in nashville and
let's be honest i look like the lead
singer of a boy band called in rehab
come on
but the best advice i can give you for
2022 and i really do mean this is to be
a republican be a democrat
whatever for republican democrat
independent just don't be an you
know what i'm saying
thank you
happy new year nashville listen to fox
across america i'm jimmy fallon good
night
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else